if you were to jump into any random spot
in the ocean you'd probably see
something like this empty of large
animals because we have taken them out
of the water faster than they can
reproduce today I want to propose a
strategy to save ocean life and the
solution has a lot to do with economics
in 1999 a little place called cabo pulmo
in mexico was an underwater desert the
fishermen were so upset not having
enough fish to catch that they did
something that no one expected instead
of spending more time at sea trying to
catch the few fish left
they stopped fishing completely they
created a national park in the sea
eh no-take marine reserve when we return
10 years later this is what we saw what
had been an underwater barren was now a
kaleidoscope of life and color we saw it
back to pristine in only 10 years
including the return of the large
predators like the groupers the Sharks
the jacks and those visionary fishermen
are making much more money now from
tourism when we can align economic needs
with conservation miracles can happen
and we have seen similar recoveries all
over the world so I spent 20 years
studying human impacts in the ocean but
when I saw firsthand the regeneration of
places like Kalpana that gave me hope so
I decided to quit my job as a university
professor to dedicate my life to save
more ocean places like this in the last
10 years our team at National Geographic
pristine seas
has explored surveyed and documented
some of the wildest places left in the
ocean and work with governments to
protect them these are all now protected
covering a total area half the size of
Canada these places are the yellow
stones and the Serengeti of the sea
these are places where you jump in the
water and are immediately surrounded by
sharks and this is good this is good
because the Sharks are a good indicator
of the health of the ecosystem these
places are time machines that take us to
the ocean of a thousand years ago but
they also show us what the future ocean
could be like because the ocean has
extraordinary regenerative power we have
seen great recovery in just a few years
we just need to protect many more places
at risk so they can become wild and full
of life again but today only 2% of the
ocean is fully protected from fishing
and other activities and that's not
enough studies suggest that we need at
least 30% of the ocean and the
protection not just to save marine life
but to save us too because the ocean
gives us more than half of the oxygen we
breathe food it absorbs much of the
carbon pollution that we throw in the
atmosphere we need a healthy ocean to
survive now is there a way to accelerate
ocean protection I think so and it
involves us looking at the high seas now
what are the high seas
now coastal countries have authority
over 200 nautical miles from shore
everything beyond those areas are called
the high seas in dark blue on this map
no country owns the high seas no country
is responsible for them but they all are
so it's a little like the Wild West
and there are too many types of fishing
in the high seas at the bottom
and near the surface bottom trolling is
the most destructive practice in the
world
super trawlers the largest fishing
vessels in the ocean have nets so large
that they can hold a dozen 747 Jets
these huge nets destroy everything in
their paths including deep corals that
grow on Simmonds which can be thousands
of years old and fishing near the
surface targets mostly species that
migrate between the high seas and
countries waters like tuna and sharks
and many of these fishes are threatened
because of too much fishing and bad
management
now who fishes in the high seas until
now it was difficult to know exactly
because countries have been very
secretive about the long-distance
fishing but now satellite technology
allows us to track individual boats this
is a game changer and this is the first
time we are presenting the data that you
are going to see I'm going to show you
the tracks of two boats over the course
of a year using a satellite automated
identification system this is a long
liner fishing around the southern coast
of Africa after a few months fishing
there the boat goes to Japan to resupply
and shortly after here it is fishing
around Madagascar this is a Russian
trawler fishing probably for cod in
Russian waters and then across the high
seas of the North Atlantic thanks to
global fishing watch we have been able
to track over 3600 boats from more than
20 countries fishing in the high seas
they use satellite positioning and
machine learning technology to
automatically identify if a boat is just
sailing or fishing which are the white
spots here so with an international
group of colleagues we decided to
investigate not only who fishes in the
high seas but who benefits from
my colleague Quan moraga at the
University of California Santa Barbara
has produced detailed maps of fishing
effort which means how much time and
fuel is spent fishing in every pixel in
the ocean we have map for every country
China Taiwan Japan Korea and Spain alone
account for almost 80 percent of the
fishing in the high seas when we put all
of the countries together this is what
we get because we have we know the
identity of every boat in the database
we know its size its tonnage the power
of its engines how many crew are on
board with this information we can
calculate fuel costs labor costs etc so
for the first time we have been able to
map the cost of fishing in the high seas
the darker the red the higher the costs
thanks to our colleagues at the
University of British Columbia we know
how much every country is actually
fishing and we know the price of the
fish as it comes of the vessel combined
with the data on effort we have been
able to map the revenue of fishing the
high seas the darker the blue the higher
the revenue we have costs and we have
revenue so for the first time we have
been able to map the profitability of
fishing in the high seas now I'm going
to show you a map red colors mean we are
losing money by fishing in that part of
the ocean blue colors mean it's
profitable here it is it seems mostly
profitable but there are two more
factors we have to take into account
first recent investigations reveal the
use of forced labor or slave labor in
high seas fishing companies use it to
cut hearts to generate profits and
second every year governments subsidize
high seas fishing with more than four
billion dollars let's go back to the map
of profits if we assume fair wages
which means not slave labor and we
remove the subsidies from our
calculation the map turns into this
fishing is truly profitable in only half
of the high seas fishing grounds in fact
on aggregate subsidies are four times
larger than the profits so we have five
countries doing most of the fishing in
the high seas and the economics are
dependent on huge government subsidies
and for some countries on human rights
violations what this economic analysis
reveals is that practically the entire
high seas fishing proposition is
misguided what same government would
subsidize an industry and curd in
exploitation and fundamentally
destructive and not so profitable anyway
so why don't we close all of the high
seas to fishing let's create a giant
high seas reserve two-thirds of the
ocean a modeling study from a modeling
study from colleagues at the UC Santa
Barbara suggest that such reserve would
help migratory species like tuna recover
in the high seas and part of that
increased abundance would spill over
into the country's waters helping to
replenish them that would also increase
the catch
in these waters and so the profits
because the cost of fishing would be
lowered and the ecological benefits
would be huge because these species of
large predators like 2/9 sharks are key
to the health of the entire ecosystem
therefore protecting the high seas would
have ecological economic and social
benefits but the truth is that most
fishing companies don't care about the
environment but they would make more
money by not fishing in the high seas
and this would not affect our ability to
feed our growing population because the
high seas provide only 5% of the global
marine catch
because the high seas are not as
productive as near shore waters and most
of the catch of the high seas is sold as
upscale food items like tuna sashimi or
shark fin soup the high seas catch does
not contribute to global food security
so how are we going to do it how are we
going to protect the high seas as we
speak
negotiators at the United Nations are
beginning discussions on a new agreement
to do just that but this cannot happen
behind closed doors this is our greatest
opportunity and we all should ensure
that our countries will support
protection of the high seas and get rid
of subsidies to industrial fishing in
2016 24 countries and the European Union
agreed to protect the Ross Sea the
wildest places in Antarctica full of
wildlife like killer whales leopard
seals penguins and this included fishing
nations like China Japan Spain Russia
but they decided that protecting such
unique environment would be worth more
than exploiting it for relatively little
benefit and this is exactly the type of
cooperation and willingness to set aside
differences that we are going to need we
can do it again if twenty years from now
our children were to jump into any
random spot in the ocean what would they
say a barren landscape like much
overseas today or an abundance of life
or legacy to the future thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]